an update now on the man who killed
eight people and himself at a fedex
warehouse in indianapolis last week
police say 19-year-old brandon holm
bought his two rifles
after his family reported him as a
mental health risk
indiana is one of at least 17 states in
washington d.c with a red flag law
that allows a judge to prohibit someone
from buying a gun
but hole was not on the state's red flag
list
this despite that he was questioned by
the fbi last year after his mother told
police he may try to commit suicide by
cop
he was detained for mental health
reasons and then he was evaluated by
mental health professionals
the prosecutor's office can go forward
with that paperwork and submit it to the
courts
then the courts determine whether or not
that person is a dangerous person
and is able to possess a firearm
the case did not go before the court the
marion county prosecutor's office says
it is currently reviewing
those records if you look at this
graphic you'll see that gun violence in
our country is surging with three
incidents yesterday alone
leaving at least six people dead since
the beginning of march the u.s has had
at least 78
mass shootings that's incidents where
four or more people
were shot